but you know who should be worried right
now
the democratic party
a recent report by nbc news
says that by all indicators
the democrats are basically poised for a
mid-term shellacking
in 2022
now
before we even get into any of these
indicators let's talk about history
right
and this is something that i'm sure
david's talked about i know i've talked
about it and yes typically the party
that retakes the white house will end up
losing the midterms
in the following election
happened to obama it happened to trump
it happened to clinton it happened you
know it happens it happens it happens
historically you're more likely to lose
that first midterm than you are to win
it obviously there are a couple of
exceptions out there
but that's typically what happens so
even just historically
biden and the democrats would be poised
to lose
but this nbc news report says hold up
now folks
it's a little bit more involved than
even just that
first and foremost redistricting is
happening
and because republicans control more
state legislatures than the democrats do
they get to redraw more districts than
the democrats in fact
the number here is astounding let me see
it is uh
republicans get to redraw 187 districts
democrats get to redraw 75.
yeah that's not good that's not good
especially for the party that obviously
has a very strong history of
gerrymandering
i mean if you want to look at what a
gerrymandered district looks like look
no further further than dan crenshaw's
district
you know you got your little almost a
square thing and then you got this big
long loop that curves around in a sea
scooping up all the little republican
areas it's a ridiculously gerrymandered
district
and of course with republicans getting
to redraw more than twice as many as the
democrats we're going to see more
districts that look like that
and that is unfortunate
and it's something that we can't do a
whole heck of a lot about right now
which i guess just got to sit and watch
it happen and that's terrifying
that's a horrible way to have to look at
these things but that's what it is
second big indicator
that nbc news points out is the money
right
statistically the candidate that raises
the most money has the best chance of
winning
and right now republicans are definitely
out raising democrats they have more
cash on hand than the democratic party
so that's a big advantage for them
another one
that's that actually i guess happened
after
nbc news had written this article
or they just decided not to include it
for some reason is uh afghanistan
afghanistan is going to play a role in
the 2022 midterms and because biden was
president when all this chaos happened
when the taliban retook afghanistan
it's gonna fall at his feet and
republicans are going to try to use that
to their advantage
so that is a big hurdle that the
democratic party is going to have to
overcome
and i don't know how they do it
pulling the troops out was the right
decision
the power vacuum created because of that
yes it's the failures of the united
states but it's the failures of 20 years
not just the failures of six months of
joe biden
so
unfair to put it at his feet absolutely
but republicans are going to try to do
that anyway
then of course you have kovit coming
back which again is not joe biden's
fault
but
republicans are going to try to make it
that way as we've talked about donald
trump is already trying to say that joe
biden surrendered to covid
and if kovitt is still around by the
2022 midterms
that's going to hurt democrats a lot it
really really is especially you know
what's the breakdown in the house now is
what 220 democrats to 212 republicans
another problem democrats have is that
they've got several democrats in swing
districts who are incumbents
who are not running for office or
they're seeking a senate seat instead
so those districts now become toss-ups
instead of having a strong democratic
incumbent
and
what happens when you have districts
like that where an incumbent does not
run whether it's a republican or
democrat by the way
you have to spend more money
on an unknown than you would on an
incumbent so that race even if you win
it is going to take more resources to be
able to win it
so that's a big drain on the democrats
so how do they fix this
obviously the easy answer you deliver
for the american public
they got the child tax credit going out
right now that's great
you're showing people look we are giving
you money
we're giving you money to help you
through this pandemic
so that's a positive the reconciliation
bill three and a half trillion dollars
depending on whether or not cinema and
mansion shave off some of that that
includes real tangible benefits for
pretty much every single district here
in the united states that is a must-pass
piece of legislation
and honestly i think the midterms are
going to hinge on what happens with that
reconciliation bill
if you make promises to the public as
joe biden did they promise get rid of
some student loan debt they've done a
little
but not in any kind of widespread way
that affects a lot of people
and that's unfortunate that could come
back to bite you
so if you deliver big time with this
reconciliation bill and you give people
something tangible something they can
either hold or see for themselves that
you have done
you just might stave off what could be a
midterm bloodbath
for the democratic party
so
that's where it is you know what to do
so get busy on it
i'm faring cousins in for david pakman
we'll be right back